oh ja das und neulich hab den diamanten
ist als erste mal dass ich auch mal was
schaffen liegen jetzt hallo meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen adventure web zusammen mit stell
dich mal ganz kurz vor die kennen
vielleicht manche von dem hauptkanal
minecraft pc 5 aber die haben sich jetzt
auch dazu entschlossen deutsche let's
play videos zu machen in minecraft und
deswegen haben wir gedacht wir machen
mal so ein adventure web und zwar ist
das tolle an dieser trend im web man
muss nicht hoch springen sondern man
muss runter fallen
und je mehr passt der dropper bei brad
pitt und es gibt nur ein stil und zwar
müssen wir einfach nur überleben während
wieder runter fallen und eine regel wir
dürfen keine blöcke kaputt machen
es ist auch wichtig dass wir das oft
haben helle brightness wollten uns tief
holen und weiter bis gar nicht so
wichtig aber was sehr wichtig ist es
dass wir das abwechselnd hochladen und
zwar gibt es morgen den zweiten part auf
den kanal von den beiden der steht in
der beschreibung oder ja das war es auch
schon
das ist übrigens moment warte ich glaub
ich rief auf reihe
das ist adam richtig wäre und das ist
marco marcu jahres und der screen okay
gut ich würde sagen wir fangen ja oder
nein ich glaube wir sind items dafür
dass wenn ich immer verrecken moment
josef belasten so ein bett laut major
james lee byars safe wie vor ob die
samen in rosarot hier drin hofft dass es
vielleicht ganz interessant dafür dass
wir uns schneller machen können
dafür nehme ich mir 16 mit der ich kaum
einmal im bett
na ja auch schon bei level 1 madness
klopp wir müssen einfach komma steht
dann weiter stand on the gold block in
push the button ja okay ich bin tot
ich bin auf den rat gefragt
ich bin auf den randlagen oben gefallen
ich weiß gar nicht wie das passieren
konnte moment ja ich komme nach bewegten
gefunden
jetzt schaffe ich das moment ich bin
auch echt zu blöd hier zum montag fallen
aber das ist auch schon sieht richtig
heftig aus darunter fällt eine fette
spiral habe ich jetzt bin ich schon
vorher drüber geflogen da kommen doch
richtig krasse sachen so kommen jetzt
schaffe ich das hat konzentration
kompletter versucht jetzt sind's
teleport demmin nach unten
letzter versuch du sagst es auch zu den
zuschauern ich glaube wenn wir jetzt
sage ich mal eine viertelstunde an einer
aufgabe hängen dann ist das schon uns
erlaubt das wären uns einfach mal tippen
wenn dann zwei leute fast geschafft
haben ich denke ich werde den typ fände
er es nicht schaffen wir noch gar nie
sagt alle hassen wir jetzt schon dafür
dass sie einfach nicht geschissen kriege
empfangen die ich auch keine angst
das liegt bestimmt daran dass ich im
bett und alles mit möglichen mitgenommen
habe ich bin viel zu schwer
ich hab das jetzt los
die kiste ich bin so gut das ist so
krass ist das schwarze wolle das aus
kranke map versteht ihr schon mal
gesehen
allein auf topstar sony hier city queen
des liftes fest wird auch nie work in
single player
ich bin stecken geblieben
stecken geblieben ich hoffe es ist auch
in der steiermark
ich glaube ja ich sag mal was machen
jetzt anders ich komme immer wieder den
schalter jetzt falle darunter warte
kommunikation aufzug ich mache da ich
gehe mal als erster okay ich bin ich bin
auch stecken
doch mal hier des elevator sales klippan
meint ich doch kein rom stimmt schon ich
nehme ganz gechillt die leiter um das
mir ein bisschen anzugucken nimmt
einfach die leiter so wie ich bin
die leiter und gucke mir dass er alles
ein bisschen an
check point wir haben schon im jahr ich
sehe eure füße kommt mal wieder ein
kleines stück zurück gerade von einem
die füße die ja genau der schweren
diamanten
ich bin auf dem weg auch die ruhigen
dinge brauchen zeit um
also ich würde sagen willst du ja und
sonst so zeigen 160 das ist
danke irgendwer hat hier gerade eine
motion runtergeworfen wollen wir uns pen
legen da oben hin mit dem checkpoint
haben oder wie ich bin auch durch die
map gefallen und gleich sterbe ich
wahrscheinlich ich liebe einfach mal das
bett fast schon das gefürchtete mehr
betten
da ist gar nichts dran level 2 v.re
schrecklich
habt ihr es geschafft ich komme rein
lenken lässt in ganz knapp überlebt ich
stelle mich jetzt ist doch gar nicht das
sieht echt geil version
schade das war richtig geil jetzt noch
diese neue version
warum sind hier eingeschätzt wie sieht
es dann hinter dem dingen sie aus wie
konnte man es denn schaffen da rein zu
springen das vom boden schaffen ins
wasser zu kommen
ich weiß nicht auf jeden fall eine menge
ich versuche das jetzt auch mal vorhin
bin ich aber nicht angekommen
ich komme mit springen nicht verhindern
ich versuche man den anderen dingen zu
den anderen aufzug der ist ohne mich
losgefahren
aber die gemeinschaft funktionieren beim
irgendwie auch nicht
ich mach das recht darauf nichts
passiert man konnte ich locker ich bin
hochgesprungen
dann ging es bei mir auch nicht oder
wollen uns einfach gamer und machen mit
einer hoch fliegen
das geht viel schneller ich mache meinen
checkpoint auf tun sie das auch stimmt
moment wir haben gar keinen diamond
bekommen bei der letzten
ich bin jetzt auch oben
kann mich dann mein kathrein setzen er
packte hier den diamond wieder eine die
ändert etwas in das level 3 in die mitte
wo gott das ist ja schon mal für mich
ich sehe schon alles noch das ist das
was ich vorhin meinte ich weiß nicht wie
ich das gesagt marco glaube ich habe dir
doch vorhin schon davon erzählt dass er
seine fette spirale ist wir müssen wir
unterkommen
ich bin und es geschafft
ich hab den diamanten vom ok gut
ich hoffe dass auch nicht daher
einzugehen
ich probiere hier nicht ich dachte schon
er funktioniert ich bin bei mir gehen
dem einkauf hätten wir wenigstens
unseren aufzug eingebaut schauen ob du
mich überholen ich bin im game motto du
kommst nach 8a der wald nicht
wie konntest du das aber ich kann es
also ich kann da gar nicht in mainz an
brücken und kanäle wie auch nicht weiß
nicht daran wegen professioneller mein
körper langsam wird mir schlecht ging
gerne wieder den elevator angemacht das
hört man ändert jetzt wo bis dahin
ja das ist da von vorhin das war ein und
geben
was ist hier denn hier ist wieder neue
schatzmeister okay gut aber ich würde
sagen dass die nächste folge bei euch
auf dem kanal ist sagt nochmal genau wie
der kanal halsabschneider vergessen
gaming also doch weil ich doch richtig
dass unser deutscher kann habe ich mir
gedacht ja genau und zwar würde ich auch
sagen dass wir den neuesten also den
zweiten partnern als video antwort beim
ersten part senden usw
das heißt ihr findet den zweiten part
auf jeden fall morgen bei den beiden
offenen kanal und dann würde ich sagen
tschüss